China's under attack from the United
States over the corona virus pandemic
we're using the full power of government
in response to the Chinese virus now
Beijing's man in London is fighting back
there's no any come up at all
we shared information with the WTO and
the world without delay and we notify
United States from the very beginning on
the 30th of January it's here in the
city of Wuhan where the first
coronavirus cases were reported but
there remains questions about how the
disease jumped from animal to human the
White House claims there's evidence it
leaked from a laboratory nonsence says
China it's apparently willing to let
investigators in to see for themselves
but only at the right time we're open we
are transparent we have nothing to hide
we're nothing to fear you know we we
welcome international independent review
but it has to be you know organized the
w-h-o organizing international
scientists from across the world to come
into China to investigate would you
agree to that yeah of course at a
property I had a puppet but not now
he told Sky News is Mark Austin the
world's focus for now should be on
finding a vaccine but the US is accusing
China of trying to hack its medical
research - this is not the first time
that United States made such a
fabrication and the force acquisition
against China currently you know I think
this is a not only there Atlas to
undermine the international
collaboration on working together to
find the better vaccine I think vaccine
will be the final solution to the
problem the war of words but
in Beijing and Washington leaves London
treading a delicate line the health
secretary Matt Hancock will speak to his
Chinese counterpart on Friday we need to
enhance collaboration we have to know
this Varys is our common enemy so we
need to put together wizard came to the
aid to each other I to win the final
battle that's not how the u.s. sees it
one of these days Britain may be forced
to pick sides
Deborah Haines Sky News